[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sébastien chunu bonjour Merci beaucoup
Sébastien chunu d'avoir accepté notre
invitation député du Nord vice-président
du rassemblement national on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice Vess
du groupe ébrra bonjour Fabrice bonjour
Orian bonjour Sébastien bonjour monsieur
on va parler du remanimement Sébastien
Chenu mais d'abord on a appris hier par
l'élisé qu'Emmanuel Macron tiendra une
conférence de presse ce sera demain à
l'Élysée à 20h15 prévu pour durer 1h30
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de sa prise
de parole rien rien le le président de
la République est totalement démonétisé
en ce qui concerne son expression moi je
note deux choses la première c'est
l'inélégance euh du président de la
République vis-à-vis de son nouveau
Premier ministre à qui il coupe l'herbe
sous sous le pied c'est vraiment
parfaitement inélégant j'allais dire
totalement contradictoire avec la
pratique républicaine qui fait qu'on
attend que le premier ministre s'exprime
bientôt devant le Parlement dans un
discours politique général et le
président de la République vient lui
saperer finalement sa parole
publique comme il avait fait avec édoard
Philippe ça montre le peu de crédit que
donne d'ailleurs le président de la
République à son premier ministre il
considère que celui-ci n'a pas de marge
de manœuvre c'est lui qui dicte les
choses et puis mauvais coup au Parlement
aussi de s'exprimer avant que le premier
ministre Vienne présenter son discours
de politique générale oui d'accord mais
y a autre chose aussi c'est un mauvais
coup poré au Parlement oui c'est un
mauvais coup c'est un mauvais coup pé à
la démocratie parlementaire et puis
autre chose c'est que le Président de la
République nous a déjà habitué à ces
formats parce qu'on nous dit c'est une
conférence de presse XXL assez
superlatif qui à la fin ne débouche sur
rien moi je me souviens et je garde un
mauvais souvenir des débats des gilets
jaunes on nous disait c'est des heures
de débat il a parlé de tout et à la fin
que reste- de tout cela rien donc non
nous n'attendons rien mais je crois que
les Français n'attendent pas grand-chose
du président de la République on disait
c'est juste avant le discours de
politique générale qui aura lieu dans
les prochains jours on ne connaît pas
encore la date est-ce que vous demandez
à Gabriel Atal de soumettre un vote de
confiance derrière là aussi la pratique
républicaine serait que le premier
ministre puisse effectivement solliciter
la confiance du Parlement pour quelque
part partir sur de bonnes bases il ne le
fera pas Elisabeth borne quelque part on
s'y attendait Elisabeth bornne n'était
pas quelqu'un de très courageux elle
avait beaucoup de mépris pour le
Parlement mais on pourrait se dire qu'un
jeune premier ministre de 34 ans il
aurait du panache à faire cela il aurait
du courage à faire cela visiblement
c'est un manque de courage pour vous ah
oui c'est un manque de courage un manque
de panage c'est-à-dire aussi la capacité
à aller chercher une majorité de
confiance devant le Parlement à séduire
à convaincre des parlementaires
visiblement avant même d'essayer Gabri
pense qu' leemportez pas ce ventre de
confiance si jamais il le sollicite je
ne sais pas pas je ne sais pas ce que
feraiit les républicains puisqu'on voit
maintenant que la moitié de l'appareil
des républicains est dans le
gouvernement donc peut-être qu'ils
auraient envie d'aller sauver la tête du
nouveau Premier ministre comme ils l'ont
fait mais même avant ça il y a aucun
vote de il y a aucune motion de censure
que vous avez réussi à faire passer
c'est autre chose ça après la motion de
censure elle arrive dans un second temps
est-ce qu'il faut censurer le Premier
ministre avant même qu'il ait parlé ou
juste après qu'il ait donné sa feuille
de route sans connaître ses résultats
nous n'en sommes pas là nous nous sommes
des gens pragmati pour que ce soit clair
pas de vote de confiance le RN ne
déposera pas de motion de censure dans
la foulée nous nous n'avons pas pour
habitude de juger les gens avant de les
voir agir nous attendons de voir on se
fait pas beaucoup d'illusion hein
sincèrement sur ce qui va se passer mais
pour l'instant nous ne sommes pas là
nous nous attendons que le premier
ministre une expression claire savoir où
il emmène le pays pour l'instant il y a
pas grand monde qui le sait donc vous
n'en déposerez pas est-ce que vous
voterez celle de la France insoumise
elle a annoncé qu'elle en déposerait une
tout ça est très prématuré nous avons
montré que nous étions capables de voter
desémotions de censure qui venaent
d'autres bans nous avons déjà voté des
motions de censure venant de la France
insoumise nous avons déjà voté avec
d'autres groupes politiques ce que ne
font pas par sectarisme donc on attend
de voir on va écouter le Premier
ministre on va voir quelle est sa
méthode aussi parce qu'il y a le fond
mais il y a aussi sa méthode de travail
je vous disais la moitié du des LR sont
maintenant dans ce gouvernement est-ce
que ça changeagér bah les grands noms de
LR de Bruno LEM Gal aujourd'hui Rachid
adti out tous ét exclus des républicains
oui d'accord mais qui sont des pois
lourd à la base des républicains il
suffit de regarder la dernière fois que
ces gens ont été ministres c'était sous
Nicolas Sarkozi c'était il y a 15 ans
ils ont pas été ministre entre-temps il
a quand même une logique est-ce que tout
cela influe sur la ligne politique ou
est-ce que tout ça c'est de la come ce
que je crois et bien on va voir c'est
une erreur Rach au gouvernement mais
c'est si vous voulez elle est pas à sa
place selon vous non mais si vous voulez
c'est c'est de la communication c'est de
l'affichage non mais sur le fond sur le
fond mais sur le fond je sais pas si est
à sa place on va voir moi je ne sais pas
ce que rachti veut faire pour le monde
de la culture je ne la mésestime pas je
ne la sous-estime pas je ne la méprise
pas mais je suis totalement incapable de
vous dire quelle est sa pensée
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de ce
gouvernement sur par exemple
l'audiovisuel public je savais ce que
Rachid hadti militante des républicain
pensait de l'audiovisuel publicique elle
en pensait beaucoup de mal visiblement
je ne sais pas dans le cadre de ce
gouvernement ce qu'elle va faire ben là
dans Le Parisien elle a l'air d'en
penser beaucoup de bien elle dit qu'il
faut le défendre elle a donné hier une
grande interview dans le par hier
beaucoup de mal aujourd'hui beaucoup de
bien bienvenue macroni est-ce que juste
pour revenir on va faire une petite
parenthèse Rachid hadti sa nomination a
soulevé une levée de bouclier est-ce que
quand hier dans le Parisien elle dénonce
un mépris de classe elle a raison pour
vous oui il y a toujours ça de la part
d'une certaine gauche ou d'une certaine
même macronie se mépris disant si vous
n'êtes pas du sérail si vous n'avez pas
été blanchi sous le harnais des grandes
écoles et des beaux quartiers vous
n'êtes pas légitime vous êtes là par
réfraction je ne ferai évidemment jamais
ce procès nous on est d'un mouvement
politique le rassemblement national où
on pousse beaucoup la méritocratie nous
on fait élir des ouvriers on fait élir
des profs on fait élire des jeunes on
fait élire des gens qui ne sont pas des
professionnels du monde politique et en
général il ils démontrent qu'ils sont
particulièrement bons donc je ne je me
battrai toujours contre effectivement ce
genre de mépris de classe de snobisme à
de balles venant de gens qui souvent ont
eux-mêmes tout raté parce que c'est bien
beau d'avoir fait toutes les grandes
écoles du monde d'être dans les beaux
quartiers de se gargariser de mots quand
on voit le résultat qu'on produit tous
ces nuls sortis de ces grandes écoles
l'état de notre pays il y a pas de quoi
donner des leçons he elle dit aussi
Rachid adati qu'elle veut faire de la
culture une arme pour lutter contre la
radicalisation et l'islamisme répondre
au problèmes d'intégration vous la
rejoignez sur cet objectif oui mais par
exemple je lui dirais alors il faut
commencer par poser la question du Noël
berbè fêté à Marseille dans les écoles
publiques puisquon nous annonce hier que
Marseille dans ses écoles publiques
fêtera le Noël berberère qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette histoire revenir sur les
cours d'apprentissage des pays d'origine
je veux dire il faut aussi des actes
clairs pour lutter contre le
communautarisme et l'islamisation de la
société oui je pense que il y a de quoi
faire on va voir de quoi est capable
rachti de quoi est capable ce
gouvernement parce que pour l'instant on
les trouve plutôt incapa
justement puisqu'on parle d'école ça éé
un peu l'actualité du weekend avec les
déclarations de Madame oua casterra dont
on a appris qu' elle avait inscrit ses
enfants dans le privé d'abord est-ce que
vous ça vous est-ce que ça vous choque
et précisément pour la question du non
remplacement des professeurs absents
dans le public bon deux choses d'abord
madame oua Castera en disant cela et
elle a tout à fait la liberté moi je
suis attaché à la liberté mon vie donc
elle a tout à fait la liberté de
scolariser ses enfants dans une école
privée et de déplorer que l'école
publique à ses yeux ne soit pas à la
hauteur mais elle dit finalement ce
qu'elle dit est très cruel pour ceux qui
gèent l'école publique depuis des années
en particulier pour ce gouvernement
Macron et pour Gabriel Atal à ce
gouvernement qui est là depuis bientôt 7
ans et dont on voit que Madame oua
casterra elle-même ministre du
gouvernement dit que les résultats en
matière d'école publiqu sont pas à la
hauteur sur les heures non remplacées ça
dit je crois beaucoup de choses du
statut du professeur qui aujourd'hui
envie de s'engager de devenir enseignant
euh de de d'être à ce point euh
incapable de susciter le respect tant la
fonction est dévalorisé euh moi je je
tire mon chapeau euh au profs qui tous
les jours se retrouent dans ce contexte
difficile je tire mon chapeau à des
profs qui n'ont pas vu leur situation
revalorisé en particulier par Gabriel
Atal qui avait simplement revalorisé le
système de prime mais pas la grille
indiciaire des professeurs c'estàdire
qu'en fait les professeurs gagnent
toujours la même chose leur fiche de
salaire est toujours la même sauf s'ils
travaillent davantage sils font autre
chose en plus ils peuvent bénéficier
d'une prime donc on voit bien qu'on est
très loin du résultat c'est une
profession qui est très dévalorisée
comment voulez-v eu des augmentations de
salaire
je vi dire ce sont des augmentations de
prime pas la grille indiciaire la grille
indemnitaire la grille de
prime pour pour les entrants c'est c'est
extrêmement léger c'est on n'est pas du
tout au niveau de ce qu'il a et c'est en
échange et c'est en échange de de
travaux supplémentaires de de cours
supplémentaires d'un investissement
supplémentaire une précision quand même
vous évoquez la liberté est-ce que
ministre de l'éducation nationale à la
liberté d'inscrire moralement j'entends
ces enfants dans le privé bah sa que ces
élites c'était déjà le cas avec Monsieur
papendiaille inscrivent leurs enfants
dans les établissements privés parce
qu'ils déplorent le l'état des
établissements publics moi je préférais
effectivement que des ministres de
l'Éducation nationale de l'instruction
public inscrivent leurs enfants dans
l'école publique moi je suis un enfant
de l'école publique mais encore une fois
moi je reste attaché à la liberté donc
je pas faire des faux procès vous savez
il y en a qui ont critiqué par exemple
l'établissement Stanislas je ne connais
pas cet établissement en disant c'est
c'est un établissement conservateur et
cetera enfin c'est les mêmes c'est celui
où sont inscrits les enfants d'AM Milou
d' voilà ce sont les mêmes qui trouvent
toutes les circonstances aténement au
lycée avosos dans le Nord tenu par les
Frères musulmans et financés par Xavier
Bertrand pendant des années donc les
mêmes qui critiquent Stanislas trouvent
des circonstances atténuantes à avos
donc rentrons pas là-dedans gardons cet
état de la liberté mais ceux qui ont
sapé aussi l'éducation nationale c'est
tous ceux qui ont voulu amener 85 % je
crois d'une classe d'âge au bac je crois
comm on est maintenant à 90 % d'une
classe d'agobac ça veut dire qu'on
dévalorise aussi le niveau de ce
baccalauréat tout est à revoir en
matière éducative chez nous on a des
députés je pense à à Roger chudau qui
est un un inspecteur de l'Éducation
nationale qui travaille sur ces sujets
là et c'est vrai que c'est un immense
chantier enfin ça fait 7 ans qu'ils sont
là 7 ans madame ouea casterra déplore
les conséquences d'une politique menée
par ses propres amis le Premier ministre
Gabriel hatal a fait 5 déplacements
depuis qu'il est arrivé à Matignon un
par jour sur l'état thème du quotidien
des Français la sécurité l'école la
santé et le pouvoir d'achat hier il
était sur un marché à camp dans le
Calvados il a confirmé Gabriel hatal les
baisses d'impôts pour les classes
moyennes c'est une bonne nouvelle oui
mais malheureusement les les 2 milliards
de baisse d'impôt prévu ou promise
d'abord attendons de voir ça représente
à peu près 30 € par Foyet fiscal donc
pour les classes moyennes on est quand
même assez loin du compte moi je je
pense d'ailleurs je repense à cette
prime inflation voté sous Jean Castex
vous savez il y avait la possibilité de
donné pour les Français qui touchent
moins de 2000 € par mois 100 € c'est il
y avait beaucoup de gens qui étaient
concernés 38 millions de Français
qu'est-ce qu'on apprend que un plus d'un
million et demi de de Français ont
touché deux fois plusieurs fois cette
prime inflation que ça a étéit près de
200 millions d'euros de d'argent
gaspillé c'était mal ciblé c'était mal
calibré ils ont été incapables ils
avaient été incapables aussi de prévoir
le fait que si c'était malversé l'état
pouvait
euh retrouver euh ces sommes malversées
euh non franchement à chaque fois qu'ils
ont fait cette politique du chèque ça a
été un échec c'est le cas de le dire
chque échec euh et aujourd'hui cette
baisse d'impôt elle ne correspond pas à
ce qu'on peut attendre il faut aller sur
des mesures qui soient pérennes et
concrètes des baisses de taxes baisses
de la TVA des hausses de salaires nous
on propose avec Marine Le Pen une hausse
des salaires de 10 % en échange du gel
des cotisations patronnal ça c'est
concret ça dure dans le temps et les
pays qui l'ont fait je pense par exemple
aux baisse de taxes sur les produits euh
de l'alimentaire ou de première
nécessité je pense à l'Espagne au
Portugal non seulement reconduit ces
dispositifs mais ont vu leur inflation
euh baisser ou ralentir beaucoup plus
vite qu'en France dans une interview
hier au Journal du Dimanche Jordane
Bardella et Marine Le Pen une interview
commune Marine Le Pen annoncer que
Jordan Bardella serait son premier
ministre si elle accède à l'Élysée en
2027 Gabrielle Atal vous fait si peur
que ça je crois que c'était un peu euh
l'inverse c'est que euh le gouvernement
s'est dit euh en regardant les codes de
popularité on en a un qui est jeune et
populaire Gabri peut-être que ça va nous
aider àer la popularité de Jordane
Bardella dont le sondage qui est sorti
hier n nous montre que nous faisons la
course en tête aux européennes nous on
reste des gens mais pourquoi le faire
maintenant c'est une réaction aussiation
gabavait déjà indiqué du forme
officialiser une interview commune moi
je pense qu'il faut donner des
perspectives aux Français leur expliquer
où on va aller ce qu'on va faire et avec
qui on va le faire le fait que Marine Le
Pen propose dans la transparence ce
ticket au français c'est assez inédit ça
montre que on fait confiance et on a pas
eu besoin d'attendre monsieur hatal
qu'on fait confiance nous à une certaine
forme de jeunesse dans notre pays et je
pense que c'est bien de le faire
maintenant c'est bien de montrer puis
finalement Gabriel Atal comme le dit
Marine Le Pen son jeune âge valide le
fait qu'on puisse être ministre
lorsqu'on est jeune premier ministre
lorsqu'on est jeune est-ce que cette
annonce comme ça d'amblé de propulser le
président du parti à matigon ça ça
traduit pas en tout cas vous ne prenez
pas le risque ça traduise un un entre
soi quelque chose en famille euh et et
l'absence de de partenair sur les
chiquers politiques français ben le
Premier ministre c'est le chef de la
majorité alors c'est vrai que lorsqu'on
voit le pauvre Gabriel Atal on se
demande de quelle majorité il va être le
chef comment il va réussir à s'imposer
avec un président de la République qui
le malmène déjà autant et qui de façon
un peu sadique lui coupe l'herbe sous le
pied nous on souhaite évidemment
continuer à élargir c'est notre but et
vous le verrez avec à l'occasion des
élections européennes à élargir à faire
sauter les digues et puis à ti à nous
desé vers qui vers qui vers tous les
Français qui veulent qui se sont qui
sont d'accord avec nous qui veulent nous
suivre sur notre offre politique il y a
des Français à gauche qui sont d'onnê
patriotes républicains qui soutiennent
une politique basée sur l'effort le
travail l'attachement au pays évidemment
il y a aussi chez les républicains et je
pense aux électeurs moi j'ai été
longtemps un militant de cette famille
politique là le désespoir que do avoir
les militants les adhérents les élus
locaux DLR génération sacr f à qui on
demande de soutenir un candidat qui fait
4,9 % présidentiel et à qui on demande
au second tour à qui l'établishement la
direction des républicains demande de
renier ses convictions en faisant
barrage à Marine Le Pen au second tour
ça tiendra plus mais sauf que Jordan
Bardella c'est votre tête de liste pour
les européennes ça veut dire que il est
candidat tout en envisageant de quitter
son poste à mi mandat non ben à mi
mandat pourquoi le J4
2027 européen de 2024 à 202 estlu non
mais d'accord mais enfin Jordan a déjà
un mandat de 5 ans de député européens
derrière lui si les Français nous font
confiance oui il quittera le Parlement
européen pour mener les affaires de la
France je pense que le jeu en vaut la
chandelle sincèrement d'autres l'ont
fait avant lui je pense à Monsieur
séjourné qui menait la délégation
Renaissance au Parlement européen qui
devient ministre des Affaires étrangère
peut-être que c'est vrai que peut-être
ne s'était personne ne s'était aperçu
que Stéphane séjourné était député
europé 5 mois de la fin de son il était
programmé pourner vous présentez avec un
candidat qui a déjà des vues sur autre
chose oui oui nos vues sur autre chose
c'est la France madame et donc on
privilégiera toujours l'intérêt de la
France et les affaires de la France
toujours mais est-ce que c'est pas la la
preuve que le Parlement européen
finalement intéresse peu le
rassemblement national et que vous
faites plutôt de cette élection une
élection d'opposition Emmanuel Macron
non c'est une élection de mi-imandat ça
donne l'occasion de dire des choses si
effectivement les Français c'est rapael
gluxman je crois qu' disait si les
Français veulent s'opposer à
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne à
l'intégration par exemple de pays comme
l'Ukraine alors il faut qu'il vote pour
le rassemblement national oui oui moi je
pense que le 9 juin en votant pour la
liste de Jordane Bardella on donne une
autre direction à l'Union européenne on
s'oppose à un impôt européen qui est en
train d'être concocté par les tenants de
l'Union européenne on s'impose à une on
s'oppose à une baisse de la PAC oui oui
le 9 juin c'est sûr qu'on s'oppose à
cette politique là un sondage vous en
parlez he hier dans le Journal du
Dimanche vous donne 10 points d'avance
dans la tribune dimanche pardon vous
donne 10 points d'avance sur la liste de
la majorité présidentielle est-ce que
vous craignz que l'entrée en campagne de
Gabriel Atal ne réduise cet écart c'est
une bonne arme antirassemblement
national le Premier ministre non parce
que je pense que lorsqu'on essaie en
terme d'image de copier finalement le
rassemblement national les Français ne
sont pas dupes nous on reste la tête
froide on fait la course en tête nous
disons aux Français mobilisez-vous pour
le 9 juin c'est l'occasion la seule
occasion avant les présidentiels de dire
ce que vous pensez aussi de la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron et de la politique de
l'Union européenne ça tombe bien nous
combattons les deux donc on on est
serein on va faire campagne Jordan
Bardella lancera sa campagne début mars
à Marseille euh je pense que nous
prenons les choses au sérieux on ne sait
toujours pas qui sont les autres têtes
de liste vous nous permettrez
aujourd'hui de ne pas savoir qui va
mener le combat chez LR qui va mener le
combat à Renaissance on nous parle
d'Olivier verrand on a hâte de voir
Olivier verérrant monter sur un ring ce
sera in c'est un bon adversaire pour
vous ah bah ce nous on se on se réjouiss
si c'est Olivier verérrant l'homme du
mépris l'homme de la gestion ratée du
covid l'homme de la tournée de la
tournée des des mairies erenes le
ministre sans portefeuille de la
propagande euh B adversaire qui vous
irait bien manifestement l'z un peu
chois c'est vrai qu'on on aimerait bien
on se réjouissait de Monsieur séjourné
parce qu'évidemment il y avait pas grand
monde qui le connaissait mais peut-être
que Monsieur verrant c'est encore mieux
que tout le monde le connaisse parce que
quand on le connaît on peut pas le
suivre moi j'ai une autre petite
question par rapport à la position de
Marine Le Pen quant à l'Europe une
position qui semble considérablement
adouci ces dernières années avec les
présidentielles successives beaucoup de
Français l' jugent plutôt favorable à
l'Europe ce qui n'est pas le cas dans
dans sa position originelle est-ce qu'il
se trompe on n'est pas favorable à cette
Europe là c'est-à-dire que le fait de
travailler entre nations libres de
travailler ensemble on ne le remet pas
en cause on ne dit pas il faut tout
casser un peu comme le le Parlement on
ne dit pas il faut tout casser il faut
changer le mode de fonctionnement de
l'Union européenne et que l'Union
européenne redonne des pant de
souveraineté au pays et je pense que si
demain les français faisaient confiance
à Marine Le Pen le le fait même que une
présidente de la République
souverainiste qui réclame de la
souveraineté pour son propre pays et
bien soit élu amènera l'Union européne à
devoir repenser l'ensemble de son mode
de fonctionnement donc il y a pas besoin
de frexit il y a besoin de changer
profondément le mode de fonctionnement
et l'arrivée de Marine Le Pen parce
qu'elle est elle serait à la tête d'un
pays qui est l'un des principaux pays
contributeurs de l'Union européenne
obligerait l'Union européenne à se
réformer or là
actuellement rien les oblige puisque on
a un président de la République qui les
encourage et qui nous mène vers un
fédéralisme un mot Fabrice sur la loi
immigration les manifestations ce pour
le retrait de la loi immigration dans
plusieurs villes à l'appel d'association
et de syndicat euh ils ont demandé le il
demand le retrait du texte qui s'estime
inspiré par l'extrême droite le Conseil
constitutionnel saisi par Emmanuel
Macron doit rendre cette décision de 25
janvier vous craignez qu'il soit adouci
écoutez je sais pas ce que fera le
Conseil constitutionnel je trouverais
étrange que le Conseil constitutionnel
Vienne sabrer une loi qui je crois ouvre
la porte en tous les cas sur des
réalités qu'on avait pas touché depuis
longtemps notamment des prestations
sociales versées principalement aux
Français ou de toute façon à des
étrangers en situation régulière depuis
un certain temps les cautions pour les
étudiants il y a des choses qui vont
dans le bon sens tout ça est très timide
mais si le Conseil constitutionnel
commence par sabrer ça alors oui il
faudra aller vers un référendum nous
c'est ce qu'on propose avec vous dites
si à censure d'une partie de la loi il
faut aller vers un référendum mais bien
sûr parce que ça veut dire qu'en fait on
ne peut rien faire qu'il y a des
dispositions dont tout le monde dit
qu'elles sont constitutionnelle bah
écoutez je ne sais pas par exemple sur
la priorité nationale ça existe déjà
dans nos textes pour accéder à la
fonction publique pour voter il faut
être français donc la priorité nationale
elle existe dans ce cadre-là pourquoi
est-ce qu'elle n'existerait pas dans le
cadre des aides sociales voilà donc oui
effectivement je pense que si le Conseil
constitutionnel empêche le législateur
sanctionne le législateur sur ce travail
alors il faut se tourner vers les
Français avec un texte nous on a un
texte qui est prêt qu'on a déjà proposé
que Marine Le Pen a écrit écrit avec les
députés du rassemblement national et
bien comme finalement mastrich à
l'époque proposerit un texte au français
en disant est-ce que ce texte a votre
assentiment sur la politique migratoire
de notre pays où est-ce qu'on continue à
accueillir 500000 personnes par an et à
ne pouvoir reconduire personne à la
frontière un dernier mot sur un A TEX
c'est la loi sur la fin de vie est-ce
que vous appelez à une loi rapide non
pas rapide justement je crois qu'il y a
besoin de temps sur ces questions-là
moi-même et les députés du rassemblement
national auront comme souvent sur les
comme toujours sur les texte lié au
sociétal une liberté de vote moi-même je
reste à convaincre je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup d'efforts à faire sur les soins
palliatifs il y a beaucoup trop
d'hôpitaux de départements dans notre
pays qui n'ont pas de structure de soins
palliatifs et lorsqu'on traite la
question des soins palliatifs alors on
écroule en partie la question de la fin
de vie pas de référendum sur le
sujet pourquoi pas les sujets de société
tranchés par la société c'est pas une
mauvaise idée mais traitons la question
d'abord des soins piatifs parce mais ça
veut dire que vous vous souhaiteriez
deux textes à part une loi sur la les
soins palliatifs et une loi sur l'aide
active à mourir oui je pense qu'il faut
d'abord une grande loi sur les soins
palliatifs et une fois qu'on a donné les
moyens aux Français qui sont en fin de
vie d'échapper à la douleur de moins
souffrir de ne plus souffrir et bien je
pense qu'on aborde plus sereinement la
question de de la fin de vie ou de
l'aide à la fin de vie de l'aide assisté
à la fin de vie je sais pas comment le
le gouvernement d'ailleurs appellera ça
le suicide assisté l'aide à la fin de
vie peu importe est- est-ce qu'il faut
qu'il y ait le mot dit pour vous dans la
loi ah moi ça me ça me heurte à titre
personnel je suis pas sûr que en fait la
loi dans ce domaine là régissent tout il
faut des gardesfous moi je crois
fondamentalement qu'il faut aller par
palier je reste à convaincre surtout ça
je dis pas que je ferme la porte parce
que je le disais tout à l'heure moi je
suis très attaché à la liberté
individuelle au choix individuel mais
traitons d'abord la question des soins
palliatifs et ensuite on verra bien s'il
y a besoin d'une loi pour la suite donc
pas de texte en février pour vous parce
que c'est é la promesse d'Emmanuel
Macron un texte à Madame Vautrin à
Madame Vautrin qui est une ministre qui
était opposée à ce texte là qui était
opposée au mariage pour tous et qui
maintenant comme Madame dti va défendre
exactement l'inverse des convictions
qu'elle affichait il y a quelques mois
merci Sébastien Chen merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité merci Fabrice à
la semaine prochaine